uh thank you Mr Speaker today we
remember the innocent lives lost six
years ago in a terror attack on
Westminster Bridge
amongst those tragically killed was PC
Keith Palmer who sacrificed his life to
protect others police officers up and
down the country worked tirelessly every
day to keep us safe and we thank them
for that
but as we saw this week those Brave
officers are being let down Dame Louise
Casey found institutional homophobia
misogyny and racism in the metropolitan
police
I accept those findings in full
does the prime minister
Mr Speaker I joined with the honorable
gentleman paying tribute to PC Palmer
and indeed all the other police officers
who have lost their lives serving and
those who do so much to keep us safe I
was appalled Mr Speaker to read the
descriptions of the abhorrent cases of
officers who have betrayed The public's
trust and abused their powers and let me
be clear it is and was unacceptable and
should never have happened we have taken
a series of steps already and the
government will also now work with the
mayor and the Metropolitan commissioner
to ensure that culture standards and
behavior all improve at the heart of
this matter other people whose lives
have been ruined by what has happened
and I know the whole house will agree
with me that it is imperative that the
Met works hard to regain the trust of
the people it is privileged to serve
I take it from that answer that the
Prime Minister does accept the Casey
findings in full including the
institutional failures because nobody
reading the Casey report can be left in
any doubt about how serious this is and
doubt for a second that it's restricted
to the Met
the report lays bare how those unfit to
join the police are aided by Patchwork
vetting systems that leave the door open
if the government-backed Labor's plan
for proper mandatory National vetting we
could end the farce that sees different
Police recruitment standards in
different forces
will he back that plan so we can make
Speedy progress prime minister Mr
Speaker there's no need to back that
pound because we're already taking
action to tackle the issues that are
raised in the Casey report and it was
actually two months ago it was two
months ago that I met with Dame Louise
Casey and the Metropolitan commissioner
and we introduced a series of measures
for instance the College of policing is
currently updating the statutory code of
practice for police officer vetting that
all forces legally have to follow all
police forces are in the process of
checking their offices against the
police National Database and in weeks
Her Majesty's independent inspectorate
will report back on their re-inspection
of all forces vetting procedures now
that these steps of course won't undo
the terrible damage that have been
previously committed but we owe this
action and more to the victims and
survivors to ensure that such tragedies
never happen again
well the problem with the prime
minister's answer is what he's referring
to isn't mandatory how can it possibly
be right to have different standards for
recruitment in different police forces
no wonder the Casey report criticized
what she calls the government's
hands-off attitude to policing over the
last 13 years but let's call it what it
really is sheer negligence
the report also exposes
failures by the police to deal with rape
cases with officers using and I quote
overstuffed or broken fridges containing
the rape kits of victims on his watch
rape charges are 1.6
yet the government still hasn't backed
Labor's plan to have proper high quality
rape and serious sexual offenses units
in every police force why not
Mr Speaker what what Louise Casey also
says is that primary public
accountability of the Met sits with the
mayor of London
[Applause]
she described that relationship between
the mayor and the Met as in her words
dysfunctional
[Applause]
stands up he will also confirm to the
house so he will take up these matters
with the labor mayor of London so that
he plays his part
the way rape victims were treated by the
criminal justice system wasn't good
enough and that's why the government
published an ambitious rape review
action plan it's right that we've
extended operation sawteria across all
police forces in the country we've
tripled the number of independent sexual
violence advisors we've improved the
process of collecting phone evidence and
being cross-examined and since 2010
we've quadrupled funding for victim
support services that is a conservative
government doing everything we can to
support victims and Tackle predators
[Applause]
[Music]
people are fed up to the back teeth with
a government that never takes
responsibility and just tries to blame
everyone they can shout if they're proud
if they're proud of the fact that nine
over 98 of rapists are never put before
if they want to shout about that that's
their record let them shout about it
should be ashamed of yourself the truth
is simple after 13 years of Tory
government crime is out of control and
people are paying the price
Before Christmas the BBC reported the
shocking case of a woman in armthorpe
who'd been beaten with a baseball bat by
burglars three years ago nobody had been
charged with that burglary and she
couldn't sleep at night under their
watch tragically that's not an unusual
case
so couldn't the Prime Minister tell us
what's the charge rate for theft and
burglary across the country
Mr Mr Speaker actually since 2019
neighborhood crime is down by 25 percent
rape cases so let me just let me just
tell him that we are on track to meet
our Target of doubling the number of
rape cases that are reaching our court
since
since the rape review action plan was
published we've seen police referrals
double we've seen charges double and
last year there was a 65 increase in
rape convictions but importantly we also
change the law to ensure that rapists
would spend more time in prison
Shadow policing police Shadow policing
Minister say prison doesn't prevent
crime
[Music]
Mr Speaker that the Prime Minister
stands there and pretends that
everything's fine he is so totally out
of touch
he needs he needs to get out of
Westminster get out of Kensington
and and Mr Speaker I don't think
it's a big day today in the house and
it's a very important day we do want to
make progress holding us up is no
Advantage as to any of us
Mr Speaker he needs to get out of
Westminster get
you go there and tell people it's all
fine and see what reaction he gets the
answer he didn't want to give although
he knows it is four percent of cases
four percent of burglary charges are
charged 96 of theft and burglary cases
not even going before the courts burglar
is twice as likely to get away with it
now as they were a decade ago they
should be ashamed of that record
and that cul-de-sat in armed forth has
apparently seen 10 burglaries in 18
months but only one of them has resulted
in a prosecution so rather than boasting
and blaming others why doesn't he tell
the country when he's going to get the
theft and burglary charge rate back to
where it was before they wrecked
policing
first of all let me say
further away the north London
yeah and I say I
I like the lines as well but I prefer to
hear them the rather than the jeering
come on
[Applause]
Mr
no then we are going to make progress
Mr shelbrook will be buying the cheese
in the Tea Room if we're not purple
and and
they'll be Yorkshire tease Mr Speaker
uh but since Mr Speaker since the
conservatives came into Power crime is
down 50 Mr Speaker
violent crime down 40 percent burglary
The Honorable gentleman mentioned
burglary burglary down 56 why because
we've recruited 20 000 more police
officers we've given them the powers to
tackle crime and we've kept serious
offenders in prison for longer all
they've done is vote against greater
protections for emergency workers
they've opposed tougher sentences for
violent criminals and they are failing
to give the police the powers that they
need it's the same old labor soft on
crime soft on criminals
the only criminal investigation he's
ever been involved in is the one that
found him guilty of breaking the law
I
prosecuted countless rapists
on the primary I I want tougher
I am determined to hear the questions
whether it's the leader of the
opposition the prime minister so I can
sorry
I think you'll be I think you've got
your first customer for team Mr Kerns we
keep having this little problem we'll
have no more
know that just a book so please let's
get through and let's just show to some
respect to both people at dispatch boxes
okay Starbucks thank you Mr Speaker I've
prosecuted countless rapists and I
support tougher sentences but you have
to catch the criminals first and when 98
of rapists are not even been put before
the court that's a massive failure of
God and if he wants to go to arm Fort
which is in Yorkshire why doesn't he go
to that cul-de-sac when he gets out and
about Yorkshire and and ask them about
those 10 burglaries that haven't been
prosecuted the reality is after 13 years
of Tory government they've done nothing
on standards neighborhood policing has
been shattered and birdless and rapists
walk the streets with impunity yeah it's
the same every week from the Prime
Minister whether it's the cost of living
crisis crime running out of control or
the state of the NHS why is this answer
always to tell this British people
they've never had it so good
[Music]
Mr Speaker let me just address that the
issue The Honorable gentleman raised
because I said at the time I respected
the decision the police reached and I
offered an unreserved apology but for
the avoidance of Doubt speaker at the
moment that happened there was a full
investigation by a very senior civil
servant the findings of which the
findings of which confirmed that I had
no Advanced knowledge about what had
been planned having arrived early
he doesn't need me to tell him that he's
probably spoken to the report's author
much more frequently than I have
[Applause]
Luke the Prime Minister needs to answer
the question he doesn't need you to
oh I don't think we need any more let's
keep it that way prime minister
Mr Speaker we're getting on we're
halving inflation by paying 50 percent
freezing for Duty we cut it and it's the
same for this side Mr Gwen I don't need
any more from the back benches here
either
say let's come
Republican not again I'm just quite
seriously today's a very big day support
important decision going to be taken so
please I want to get this house moving
on prime minister
miss Mr Speaker we're also cutting NHS
waiting lists by resolving Bay dispute
let's back up and
Amica we're stopping the boats with a
new bill
that's a migration that's a conservative
government delivering on the people's
priorities
yeah I'll let my baby